le garde des sceaux a installé au
ministère de la justice une commission
de personnalités chargée de veiller à
l'usagé qui pourrait être fait des
informations et des renseignements
contenus dans les fichiers des
établissements publics privés par
exemple ceux des impôts de l'insee ou
simplement des compagnies d'assurance si
ces renseignements venait à être
regroupés sur une mémoire centrale
les français en fiches sur un ordinateur
on voit les menaces que cela pourrait
faire peser sur les droits privés
peut-être les libertés des individus
mais cela est il possible dans l'état
actuel des progrès de l'informatique est
d'abord comment fonctionnent ces
fichiers et bien tout ceci ce que vous
avez sous les yeux et bien c'est ce que
l'on peut appeler en quelque sorte de
fichier un fichier la caractéristique
d'un fichier c'est donc de stocker
énormément d'informations mais surtout
que ces informations on puisse aller les
rechercher rapidement alors on vous
parlait bien du fichier national et
bières dites vous bien que vous pouvoir
stocker tous les renseignements
concernant les français il faudrait non
seulement une pièce comme celle ci c'est
à dire une patrie l'ordinateur comme
celle ci il faudrait un immeuble de huit
étages
vous doutez bien que c'est quasiment
inutilisable alors eh bien une solution
pour qu'on puisse la résolution beaucoup
plus simple c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'interconnexion des ordinateurs tenir
de pouvoir consulter à l'aide par
exemple d'une machine à écrire comme
celle ci ou bien d'un simple appareil
téléphonique de pouvoir consulter à
distance un autre ordinateur et pouvoir
consulter le fichier
les gens croient encore que le plus
simple pour résoudre des problèmes
techniques
et bien c'est de partir avec une bande
magnétique comme celle ci sous le bras
et d'aller voir un autre ordinateur pour
que la machine puisse traiter la bande
magnétique seulement et bien
curité c'est à dire que n'importe qui ne
peut pas consulter la barre mythique
il ya ce que l'on appelle des verrous et
sécurité sécurité technique mais aussi
sécurité légale ce sont celles ci
précisément il faut garantir avant même
que la menace existe vraiment et le
garde des sceaux l'a déclaré le
gouvernement s'opposera à toute
initiative qui risquerait de menacer les
libertés individuelles donc pas de
fichier central et le rôle de la
commission sera précisément de veiller à
ce que ces libertés ne soit jamais
menacé à l'occasion du développement de
l' usage de l'informatique par ailleurs
de plus en plus utile